we actually introduced a new Ville on
this season that's going to be bigger
and badder than any other character you
seen in the Rick and Morty's diverse
thus far and his name is world ender he
is a giant hulking beast of a mobster
who if you think like vanos [ __ ]
Darkseid and like had a baby that babies
and [ __ ] some other a giant creature
monster that's world ender oh boy I'm
getting spooked about thinking about a
world under right now I mean look at all
the with all those freckles well brick
has been to beacon for being called to a
simple-minded meditators the indicators
are essentially of more badass version
of the Avengers we have at least seven
different heroes
we got Allen rails and summon ghost ring
what else can you need to know he's a
ghost trained summoner willful you know
we got millionaire he is a cook events
that are symbol together by one Cossack
queen and this proxy by half robot half
crocodile you decide which came first uh
yeah just a few more design notes um
Rick and Morty superheroes what stop
[ __ ] your eyes are going to [ __ ] start
bleeding when you watch this episode
because of how good it
I'm good it is we just [ __ ] pooped it
out like [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] but it is
now anyways enjoy it everybody noob Rick
and Morty drop in tomorrow this is
probably one of my favorite types of
promos that they've done so far they've
done a couple of these within about
three seconds you can tell they're all
doing a bit if you think the dark side
and Thanos had a baby and then that baby
had a baby with some other big giant
monster
that's who world ender is so even though
he does kind of look like he's out of
some sort of anime I do love the fact
that they're referencing Justice League
and Marvel stuff we sort of confirms the
inspiration for Alan Rails a lot of you
were like maybe he's supposed to be a
Green Lantern Jon Stewart analog but
instead of saying that he makes
constructs like he has the green chain
around his neck they say he creates
ghost trains so I guess that's their way
of avoiding getting sued Marvel Disney
Warner Brothers they're very litigious
but I guess that also confirms that
Crocky bot is somewhere between rocket
racoon in cyborg half robot half
crocodile you decide which came first
and even though I still think that
million ants is their version of Groot
there were a lot of you on that last
video I did that were like maybe he's
poop maybe that's what he's made of
like he'll say I am poop instead of I am
Groot but they just did all those
puppets in the last episode so that
would be a little bit nuts if they had
like a poop joke in every single episode
then you know something would be going
on behind the scenes but in reality I
think part of the reason why they did
this in this funny way like I tried a
high-power old ender like oh you think
he's bad well the baby of Santos and
Darkseid is because Rick is probably
going to kill him in the episode in
that'll be the end of it like they want
to present his extreme
and rick is pissed off that Morty is so
excited about the Vindicator that he's
probably just gonna most of this villain
like it's no big deal so with the
exception of Tammy Phoenix person and
say like zis and Fleur
most of the antagonists Rick just mows
through in every single episode so you
don't end up seeing him again or they
wind up just being referenced
offhandedly in future episodes so when
you see a challenge that seems so
insurmountable as world ender like it
just sounds ridiculous it sounds like
Wrinkle have some hilarious solution for
defeating him like look at how quickly
he got himself out of that pickle
situation and if last week's episode was
mostly about him trying to avoid having
to sit through therapy that makes me
wonder what the big threat is in this
episode because it seems like more of a
Morty episode like he's the one that's
super excited to go on this adventure so
maybe it's more about what's going on
with him besides peeing under the desk
that was great last week
peeing under the desk and huffing
pottery glaze but let me know like what
are you guys most excited for in this
episode I'm really just excited to try
and find all the Marvel and DC
references so Justin's plumber's shirt
there which is actually pretty awesome I
don't think I have a plumber's shirt I
have several Rick and Morty shirts but
not that one they just released their
vh1 behind the music for Rick and Morty
like its origins so here's a little clip
from that it's actually really cool to
listen to him talk about how it got
started and this is before YouTube so we
kind of just would create content with
no one to show it to and then our friend
shows us his website called channel 1
would calm anybody in the world that's
listening to us right now is allowed to
submit a 5-minute first episode of any
kind of television show that they want
me and Justin improv on were like so
intrigued by it so we just submitted
something we made I don't have your
cereal in it what we wear is the cereal
if they're enough for me to have a bowl
of cereal the thing we look forward to
every month was that rush and hearing
the audience react to something you made
it was it was it was like hi Justin
first of all came in kind of blowing
everyone's mind with his sensibility his
charm and his like proclivity for
professional-grade animation
hello there I'm poopy pothole Corson oh
you can call me dirty wet poopy poopy
sloppy cooler whole Justin
figured out a way to make cartoon super
fast within a month every day after work
going to Justin's apartment yeah we were
the cars we make exactly Justin would
always submit these cartoons that the
panel would love but the audience would
hate until he did House of Cosby's I'm
Dan Takata
I'm curiosity Cosby you see i'm cosby
number 6 bathtub Cosby House the Cosby's
was the catalyst for Harmon and I to
start collaborating on [ __ ] together we
both had a great deal of respect for
each other and we're fans of each other
[ __ ] that we were making no stop trying
to make us all scared like Pierce
Brosnan and Dante's Peak that was a
[ __ ] incredible time like we were all
together we're all making crazy [ __ ]
we're all admirers of each other's work
at the time none of us even realized
that this would be anything you know
we're all just a bunch of scrappy like
idiot kids making stuff that are just
goofing around the point of channel one
was to not be perfect was to just get
[ __ ] done get it out it doesn't matter
it probably won't even get voted back
the most purest version of your art
comes out that way the really cool thing
about that is it's mostly like the first
half of how all these Rick and Morty
people came together separately so you
have Dan Harmon channel 101 stuff then
you have Justin roiland coming to Los
Angeles and his friends sort of
submitting stuff to that which actually
sounds like mr. poopy butthole so I
think we just saw the secret origin to
that character they do reference the
channel 101 came before YouTube and
actually a lot of my internet friends
that I worked with at YouTube before I
started doing YouTube videos myself did
a lot of channel 101 I never got
involved with it myself but it's
actually still a thing like they still
do stuff but obviously it's changed a
lot now just because the digital space
is so different and part of the reason
for channel 101 was because there wasn't
a place like YouTube exists today for
people to post that stuff so what will
happen is is they'll probably post part
two of this in a little while and
they'll talk a little bit more
specifically about the origins of Rick
and Morty itself this would just sort of
their Avengers Assemble version of that
like how do all these different people
find each other so we'll say there's a
new round of the
Rick and Morty merch giveaway I'll
announce the winner when I post my
episode 4 video that'll be Monday just
like normal
obviously Game of Thrones is going to be
posting tomorrow too so all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video while you wait for
everything you can click here for my
episode 3 Easter eggs and you can click
here for the trailer for that next
episode of Game of Thrones thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]